this is dennis kucinich I grew up in
Cleveland Ohio the oldest of seven
children and my parents never owned a
home we were renters by the time I was
17 we lived in 21 different places
including a couple cars that experience
of growing up in the inner city which
I've outlined in a book that I've just
released called the courage to survive
is an experience that really had an
indelible imprint upon the way I look at
the world and upon my soul because it
taught me compassion what people go
through to just try to make it day to
day the importance of a job of health
care of being able to put food on the
table and clothes on kids backs the
important of education you know these
are all things that are part of people's
practical aspirations and having been
riveted in that experience growing up in
Cleveland I understand as someone
aspiring to be President of the United
States how in terribly important all of
these things are for people so I'm my
worldview is truly shaped by that
experience and growing up and I know the
whole world didn't live in conditions
that were their poverty and I know that
but I also know that those who do don't
have many spokes persons and government
you